in this video I want to talk a little
bit about the actual details of the base
pair hydrogen bonding and I also want to
talk about melting temperature so if you
recall the purines were pure as gold or
pure as silver and the purines were
adenine and guanine and G and the
perimeters were cut the PI right or
pyramids that sharp edges that cut so C
UT cytosine yourself I mean now when we
also know that a z-- pair in DNA eres
pair with T's and C's pair with G's so
it's always a purine and pairing with a
primitive or in a pyramid Ian right
pairing with the purine so this brings
up this idea of chargaff's rule so this
dude chargaff he came up with this rule
that the number of purines must equal
the number of pyramids so basically the
number of a's right purine will equal
the number of T's and the number of G's
will equal the number of C's so it's
always a purine pairing up with the
perimeter in the base pairs so each base
pair is a purine and a per to Medine
that's always the case it's never a
purine an appearing and never a
permitted inner perimeter that doesn't
happen that doesn't happen and that
makes sense because if you recall
purines had two rings and Prometheans
have one ring so basically if you think
about the length of the actual hydrogen
bond we have like a two rings plus one
ring right if we had two purines that
would be two two ring structures that
would be too long if we add two per
Imogene's that would be too short so if
we have one purine and one pyrimidine
pairing up all the time we always have
essentially three rings total and that
the DNA strand would wouldn't have to
what be wider at certain areas and
shorter or narrower at certain areas so
I want to sort of draw out the actual
hydrogen bonds between the the groups
--there so in an 80 pair we've mentioned
before that there are two hydrogen bonds
so the way those two hydrogen bonds look
is if we have here this is an adenine
and this here is a thymine so the
hydrogen bonds the two hydrogen bonds
that exist between them are right here
and right here so here this amino group
is the H bond donor and that carbonyl
group oxygen is the H bond acceptor here
this end with the H on it is the H bond
donor and this here is the H bond
acceptor so these are the two H bonds in
an 80 base pairs in the case of GC base
pairs there are three H bonds in the way
those look is if you have this quantity
with a guanine base in this cytosine
base three H bonds exists right here
this is one of them this is the other
and this is the third okay you notice I
wrote SP here SP here SP here SP here
that just indicates sugar phosphate so
that's a sugar phosphate backbone I
didn't want to draw it all in I just
really just wanted to focus on the
actual hydrogen bonds to how they look
so this brings me to the idea of melting
temperature so melting temperature
otherwise known as TM is the temperature
at which the DNA double helix separates
into two strands so if we have a single
strand on all that on the left side and
the right side is a another single
strand they're held together by these H
bonds so if we want to melt those two
strands apart then we're going to have
to break those H bonds so what we can do
is we can add Heat right so what does
the actual low melting temperature
depend on it the same
well the simplest thing I can say is it
depends on GC content now why is that
well eighty base pairs have two hydrogen
bonds GC cons or GC base pairs have
three H bonds so if we wanted to melt
these two apart versus melting these two
apart what would be harder well it's
it's pretty simple right
the GC base pair because as more H bonds
it would be harder to break apart so if
you have a DNA strand that has a higher
GC content then it would be harder to
break apart right harder to take those
or melt those strands apart so they will
have a higher melting temperature that
makes sense right just to give you a
quick example if you had double strand
two sets of double-stranded DNA
once that had and they both have 100
base pairs what one of them has 70 GC
base pairs and the other has 30 GC base
pairs which one would have the higher
melting temperature the one with the
more GC s right the one with the 70 GC s
that's just because it would require
more heat to tear those two strands
apart just to give you a quick visual
imagine this so this is a DNA strand
here or a double-stranded DNA here now
if we add some heat what's going to
happen if we add heat we're going to
begin to melt that strand apart we're
gonna begin to melt these H bonds apart
we're going to break them up and so the
strands begin to come apart if we add
some more heat eventually these strands
will become single-stranded they'll be
we will have broken all of the hydrogen
bonds this process you might have
already heard the term associated with
it it's called denaturation or
denaturation and that's really just
melting the strands apart so what if we
wanted to bring the strands and put them
back together well we would have to do
is we want to instead of add a heat we
would do the opposite of that we would
want to cool it down so we cool it down
and eventually the strands would come
back together that process would be
called renature
another term associated with this is
rien eeling of the strands for the
strands would really let's come back
together so I hope that was a helpful
overview of what's going on with those
base pairs one last thing I am a tutor
if you live in Southern California feel
free to contact me via email at Louvre
University at gmail.com and see the
description below for more details
thanks for watching